can we watch this people are begging us
to watch this
and i really think it's one of the
funniest tick tocks i've ever seen in my
entire life
uh let it rip oh by the way
we cannot we cannot talk about
what wait why i can't see your face hold
on
uh-oh what we can't talk about
um blake saul
people said enough i'm like
oh oh blake saul yeah yeah okay well we
will why don't we give it two minutes
and and um brogan doll
we're not allowed no more they said no
more
we can call him oh yeah oh dude like
plate jaw
pink jaw y'all more like jake paul more
like played
[Laughter]
all right y'all right here i gotta i
gotta mute it though because the music
is copyrighted so maybe
nate let's put some let's put some like
maybe like some heart
uh uh heart what's the word [ __ ] tug
on your heartstrings music for this all
right little sad music
yeah a little sad in the zone um voter
route okay
this is from a guy his name's alex
something
mikhail whatever
[Music]
here let's read it for the people that
are just listening okay it's this hockey
looking guy standing there
this guy could not be more calgary yeah
yeah this is where he's from too he's
from calgary this is every kid
that i knew in high school okay
literally
the new girl it says his friend saying
this the new girl is huge
gross look at her and he like nods and
he goes shut up guys
and he comes up here he goes i'm sorry
about that it's okay i get it all the
time i'm alex by the way i'm christy
nice to meet you want to go for lunch
his friends she's gross why would you go
for lunch with her alex he said shut up
guys
don't listen to them you pick the place
and i'll pay
let's go thanks for lunch alex
of course so you're new why calgary
well my dad passed away six months ago
and my mom couldn't afford our place we
lived in so
she got a job here
[Music]
i'm so sorry so i've been depressed and
gained a bunch of weight it's been hard
i'm completely understand also why
didn't he get rid of i'm so sorry
underneath
[Music]
that's it for part one so man
there's like three more parts of that is
this like the
calgary riverdale or something outer
banks
that [ __ ] is isn't that [ __ ] absurd
just that first line who yo that girl is
huge
i just want to say like it's it's funny
to create a scenario like that because
you have to write that part too
yeah that's right like you're acting you
write yourself as the hero but you also
wrote those insults at the beginning
you fabricated this situation of some
[ __ ]
big girl getting made fun of dude did
you see that retweet this [ __ ] i mean
cackling
it was it was it was like yeah thinking
about the time this dude called me like
a fat ass like in real life or
at whatever if you knew what the [ __ ]
that was like
oh it's like some kick-ass shitty bar
oh my god it's so funny actually it's
not kick-ass
in any way it's actually just shitty
oh man that's so funny damn
damn i saw a tick tock it was a
girl driving and she said she's younger
she's like
boys are so weird and why is it that
every group of boys goes through a phase
where they're just moaning
and i just chuckled and thought it never
ends
actually yeah it's not a phase it's not
a phase
not a phase sorry you actually start a
whole podcast based on it
you can do a whole podcast but speak oh
wait wait speaking of the podcast we
have to shout out
you know a very a couple listeners
um i actually don't know their names all
i know is this person's name is captain
morgan on twitter
okay and this is something we talked
about in our live show
before the you know pen before
coronavirus hit and it's that there is
an insane amount of you that have sent
us
pictures or messages saying i just
totaled my car listening to the podcast
oh yeah
yeah and so we have to shout out captain
morgan we'll send these pictures to nate
um what what let me let me just make
sure i get the
uh time stamp here
because uh this girl this girl so it was
her and her friend
and they wrecked their [ __ ]
scroll up in the thread you see it yeah
i do
um so shout out to you guys you know
hopefully your insurance covers that you
know
maybe you don't want to you know maybe
we need to leave out your name so you
can get your insurance claim but holy
[ __ ]
hold on i'm pulling it up hold on oh are
there it is right there
you see it
the growth on tick tock podcast was
great may have caused some light
chuckles in a total vehicle ha ha
that thing is [ __ ] up how did you do
that
how is it so [ __ ] up on the front the
side and the back
like that's what i don't get man
you guys did like a like a
like a mission impossible scene or
something like 360 tail whip
yeah that is crazy man i'm good for you
guys
your car got in a fight i wasn't
i have to dude it's car their car
literally has a black eye
yeah yeah wow you [ __ ] it man
good for you guys i mean i'm sorry
yeah we're definitely sorry but that's a
good thing right no it um
you know selfishly i take it as a good
thing because that means we're still
hitting
we haven't lost a touch yeah exactly
yeah yeah i mean i gotta
admit i went back and watched the lewis
hamilton thing i was dying
[Laughter]
yo someone said he has a song with
christina aguilera
what really i was do we have to do that
on the bonus
we got to watch that in the box i read
that and lost my noodles i said what
i do remember he was on instagram live
like recording himself rapping and [ __ ]
i
could i couldn't watch oh no yeah
oh no [ __ ] formula one is the
greatest reality show on earth
wow
you